à bourganeuf après des attentats qui ont
visé la communauté turque
l'administration a réagi en dépêchant 15
gendarmes qui viendront en renfort de
leurs collègues
en plus des démarches judiciaires déjà
entreprises et que nous avons relaté les
réactions sont nombreuses dans cette
localité creusoise et pour certains la
sphère devient politique
michel taubmann et claude sarlat ont
enquêté sur le climat qui règne dans la
ville
voici l'heure on a peur monsieur mais
vous avez peur des immigrés ou temps de
la violence violence peur étrangers des
mots qui depuis dix jours alimente
toutes les conversations à bourganeuf
deux attentats à la chevrotine contre
les travailleurs turcs
puis une alerte à la bombe suivie de
coups de feu contre la mairie mme se
déroule à une réunion de la cgt ont fait
perdre sa sérénité à la commune
creusoise l'inculpation de trois
personnes dont un armurier et un
gendarme a ravivé les patients contre
toute logique puisque les agresseurs ont
reconnu leurs actes les victimes sont
devenus pour certains des boucs
émissaires
bien trop pourquoi je te parle y en a
trop et puis sommes tous assis des
heures sur les terrasses et pistolet sur
les marches de l'église heures il faut
pas dire qu'ils travaillent tous ses
scores mais en quoi ça vous dérange vous
mais ça me dérange pas c'est bien pour
ça il y en a trop quand même
vu la crise actuelle après partir je
sais pas on les a fait rentrer
maintenant ça doit être très compliqué
mais je pense qu'il faudrait que ces
acquis en franca minc et qui étend de
d'émigrés qui rentre il vit parfois 4
si dans une pièce de quinze mètres
carrés dépourvu de sanitaires qu'importe
la réalité on leur reproche de prendre
les logements des français on en annonce
400 on craint l'arrivée de camions
entiers
ils ne sont pourtant que 53 53 turque
sur 4000 habitants leur nombre décroît
même de fille l'an dernier 53 arrivé
depuis une dizaine d'années dans une
région forestière où les jeunes français
ne plus être bûcheron 10 heures de
travail par jour y compris le samedi
payés à la tâche c'est à dire au mètre
cube de bois coupé salaires entre 3000
et 4000 francs par mois
une vie qui ne devrait pas susciter de
jalousie voyait d'ailleurs deux parties
qui s'affrontent royal est le parti qui
soutient et les étrangers là c'est le
parti communiste puisse affronter
lectures pierre laur 16 académies
touchées seront d'un côté le fait que
deux des tireurs seraient proches de
l'opposition
de l'autre la cgt à laquelle des
bûcherons turcs ont adhéré peu avant
l'attentât
une municipalité de gauche et une amical
france turquie qui les ont aidé à
s'intégrer en évitant la constitution
d'un ghetto il n'en fallait pas plus
pour politiser la fête locale à feu
n'est pas en france un cas particulier
ce n'est pas une enclave au centre de la
france où il se passerait des choses
extraordinaires
nous intégrons ce qui s'est passé à
morgan à ce dans un contexte national
est un contexte de déstabilisation des
institutions en place à bourganeuf comme
ailleurs on passe par l'attentât raciste
pour arriver à ce phénomène de
déstabilisation parce que l'attentât
faciste raciste c'est toujours facile ça
a toujours un certain impact sur le
public
il ya toujours de l'action un petit peu
dans le désordre
d'après vous c'est un problème politique
c'est un problème tout le monde sait que
le pouvoir a changé de mains il ya
quelques années
eh bien depuis ce changement du pouvoir
on assiste un petit peu partout et de
plus en plus de façon de plus en plus
musclés à deux problèmes une
déstabilisation pouvoir en place et
pourquoi pas un organe est ce comme
ailleurs les arbres coûté quatre
millions d'étudiants l'envoi de renforts
de police hier à bourganeuf devrait
désormais assurer le calme dans la rue
mais les esprits sont loin d'être
apaisées
bourganeuf une édifiante démonstration
il suffit parfois de quelques coups de
feu pour révéler des sentiments profonds
d'intolérance la descente